I heard that you are writing is this
right you're writing a book what kind of
Bucky writing Oh like I was working with
Amy Simons she's the incredible actor
writer director and we started making up
jokes together and have been talking
about this joke book that I'm gonna
write a joke book yeah I thought so and
I thought I know we're doing a talk show
right now but I thought maybe you could
give me pointers I think you could find
better people to give you a pointer but
yeah sure I mean yeah I would be ugly
glad to help you yes so these are jokes
that you guys have written these are
jokes that we've written and we
anticipate to write a joke book okay so
the first one is what did the shower
head say to the conditioner what did the
shower head say the conditioner I don't
know get out of hair
I'm sure you have little lights that say
no no that was I think I believe
authentic yeah it's the first authentic
laughter I've heard in the studio in
years
the I also like your delivery it's very
great like that I mean I have why I'm
very like yeah I have more oh you have
more okay sure um one is what is what is
uh what do you call an insect that's in
trouble with the law I don't know
a defendant would you like to try
another so when you stand up you're
gonna go out and do those two jokes and
then say good night everybody I love
that
you